liberal leaders are speaking out now
about a surge in violent crime president
biden met today with big city mayors and
talked about what to do about the
problem he also pledged a whole lot more
money for police departments meanwhile
california's governor that's gavin
newsom rolled up his sleeves and started
picking up trash right off of the train
tracks this after an explosion in train
robberies has left l.a littered with
discarded packages
it looked like a third world country
these images the drone images that were
on the nightly news how do we make sure
we don't have to keep coming back
how do we secure this site how do we do
a better job and making sure
that this doesn't have to continue to
happen this is the supply chain i know
all of us are focused down on the water
it's so damn beautiful and everybody's
just focused on containers at the ports
the supply chain
while promising a crackdown on crime the
democratic governor also was very
careful with his words take a listen
this is organized theft
these are organized gangs of people that
are coming out and forgive me for saying
gangs i know that
that's not a pejorative
they're organized groups of folks
that
move from site to site
well greg you heard the governor there
he said all these robberies are making
his state look bad he also says it is a
supply chain problem a supply chain
problem is that why all the grocery
store shelves are empty again first i
just want to say it's good to see you
back after becoming a birthing person
jillian thank you
i trust i trust you have not picked a
gender yet and you're waiting for the
right time
so we're gonna leave it up to you i i
i've decided i i will let you know in a
uh in a gender reveal you know
what was he just talking about that he
was apologizing for saying gang yeah
like it was like he was he was afraid
that he was insulting the criminals oh
you know these gangs
wait
uh roving criminals i mean that was
bizarre so why did it take so long for
democrats to prioritize crime when it
was when americans were suffering for
almost two years why do they choose to
chase the voting bill or climate their
climate agenda it's simple because you
can't chase a problem that everyone
knows you cost right it's like saying
crime is out of control as a progressive
democrat everybody looks at you go well
isn't that on you so they have to avoid
it also they're with who they consider
adversaries which would be people like
us on fox or
republicans this is a really key issue
for them and so the democrats can't be
seen
like agreeing with us because that would
be betrayal so they would rather pick a
really stupid stance you know like
bailing out looters right or um no cash
bail than actually common sense because
the common sense is aligned with other
people so they they kind of despise us
more than they did despise the thugs so
that's why the thugs are out there
newsom should repeal a bunch of those
laws that allow people to shoplift like
900 bucks worth of crap that would be a
start instead of this symbol the
symbolic virtue signaling that he does
outside this is not a practical solution
what he's doing this is just for
for our us to do segments and it worked
harold um i'm going to come to you next
to respond because these are your people
so in the span of two days we had nancy
pelosi saying you know crime's my number
one issue then the president says i want
to give police departments more money
what gifts
so i think we should be careful not to
frame this in a partisan way the cities
in miami jacksonville tulsa fort worth
all have republican mayors and some of
those have republican governors but i
wouldn't dare call this
something that they they want or
enabling i do think greg is right to an
extent when he says that democrats have
not come out strong enough
some of our rank and file around
defunding and some of a rank and file
around
some of this cash bail reform i would
hope that every d.a and every police
chief and a lot of democratic police
chiefs a lot of democratic mayors
including eric adams who howard argues
probably to the right of president biden
on some of these issues and perhaps some
of the mainstream talk in my party
around what to do and how to prosecute
crime but one thing is clear no black
america no democrat that i socialize
with and i am one
once once high crime rates wants high
homicide rates or wants to have to clean
debris off of railroads i would hope
that mayors around the country and many
of them are in washington today the
president spoke with them i would
imagine that many of them probably asked
this president help us with bell reform
help us with a mental health initiative
help us to ensure that those of us who
have public transit systems that were
able to prosecute arrests and
and make safe uh havens there on on
subway platforms all across across the
country i didn't mean to jump start this
conversation in the last segment but i'm
glad that the district attorney in new
york met with business leaders today and
i'm glad they expressed very clearly to
him that without a public transit system
without a safe one and we've all
commented on this new york won't be new
york our economy can't thrive so i hope
democrats and republicans those who have
been wrong get right and those who've
been right all along continue to amplify
your voice
uh jesse the transportation security
administration the tsa confirmed to fox
news now
that they are allowing undocumented
immigrants people who are in the united
states illegally to use their homeland
security issued arrest warrants
as id at airport security checkpoints
those arrest warrants are used to cross
check with cbp databases i as far as i
can tell this is great news for you
because now you don't have to bring your
passport anymore you can just bring your
arrest warrant you must have multiple
jesse uh multiple um
very very devious behavior on my part
and i will submit to a full body search
but i wanna not gloat for a second a lot
of people are gonna be shocked when i
tell you this i'm not gonna trash the
democrats here don't change the channel
just hear me out
the democrats have come around on crime
let's take the win the democrats have
come around on lockdowns on school
closings they finally have woken up to
the train wreck of the biden presidency
i'm not going to spike the football i'm
just going to accept it all right
so
i don't think their intentions are pure
obviously it's very suspicious that
pelosi newsom and biden on the same day
are laser focused on crime that tells me
this that tells me a polling memo went
out that the democrats saw
and looked at and said holy cow we're
all going to lose our seats now a crime
is not when someone steals your car or
takes your wallet a crime is when
someone steals a democrat's seat in
congress that's what they care about
same thing happened after the 2020
summer riots remember they didn't give a
damn all summer until the polling memo
went out in august and don lemon said
guys you guys are gonna get crushed
you know bad polls are like smelling
salts wakes the democrat party up but
you know that that is the real issue now
also did you notice how gavin newsom
didn't really care about the criminals
or the or the crime itself he cares
about the image
of the crime he cares about how it looks
on television did you see the drone
footage it was on the network news
i mean it's really like a pr thing for
him it's so superficial and i fear
that good-looking guys with great hair
are just
so superficial it's giving us a bad name
it's chuck
so it's hand in hand with what greg just
said you know the optics you know what
he's concerned about what he calls these
girls dig and i obviously saved the
loveliest for last
thank you
greg's offended
gavin newsom has his eye on higher
office number one and these pictures
were embarrassing to him also union
pacific the railroad wrote georgia
gascon the district attorney in los
angeles county a two-page letter
essentially telling him if you don't
start prosecuting these crimes they
wrote in the letter even with all the
arrests made the no cash bail policy an
extended time frame for suspects to
appear in court is causing
re-victimization to union pacific
employees by the same criminals to the
railroad and to the employees they said
we're taking our business out of la
county potentially so what happens is
gavin newsom knows this is the beginning
of a downward spiral a financial death
spiral for any city and any state if the
businesses leave your tax base leaves
even more wealthy taxpayers will leave
and then lower income californians are
left behind and you can't recover from
that but to
greg's point
i think the only thing that triggered
gavin newsom going down there was his
gucci slippers got lost in transit
or some hermes some hermes foulards that
he ordered got stolen because it's
supposed to be here by now but it's only
when they only start caring to quote
greg gutfeld about crime or about any
issue or even acknowledge it
when it happens to them
great point um that's greg's point i
stole it that's okay someone's stealing
my point jesus no one wants your points
jesse we gotta leave it there coming up
next